[Music]
and child criminal news yup [ __ ]
competitive I button Lily hey it's
actually an early stream but fan teams
with 126 arrests are now also facing
murder charges at their stolen car crash
kills three of their friends why do you
run into their friends for or teen side
story we me and Khalif and the rumors
were children and we were talking about
you know past people that we had crushes
on since we were kids
so I looked up this one girl so that
we're looking up my facebook to see what
they were doing it for fun right just
kind of going into your patch to see
these people you like how they're doing
now like Hillel judges one chick I'll
leave her name out of it but we looked
her up and I wonder how she was I
remember she was super cute looks rough
she passed away woman too same situation
Gump diving Clark I thought he was drunk
driving in the car as she was the
passenger she died don't go out at night
guys drinking do not drink and drive
just don't go outside uber there's no
excuse for that now because there's so
many different ways to get back home now
I so said it reminded me of that I got
really second I'll super hype to see
when she turned out to be we saw a
picture of her because her sister would
have wrote a blog on her so pretty all
it sucks when pretty people die but when
they're ugly it's alright it's alright
that's not bad you know this story
this group of teams they stole two cars
from a dealership and these people need
to be fired from their jobs that's why
they went on a test drive and they
kicked out the tail something on the
side and I think that dealership not
even close how do you get the keys I did
not have a stylised on the dealership
made it inside jolly probably work like
oh yeah anyone either help get your
girlfriend to go through this that's a
little dick swipe the key out you get
the keys I know how we call all these
kids are 14 16 won 18 Umi cents a lot of
digits 1 2 3 4 5 6
six teams in lost okay that's about the
age I think I would probably be willing
to do the craziest [ __ ] and I did I feel
like nobody can catch me yeah so what
happened was they after stealing those
cars they went to go pick up friends and
they drove around in there smoking weed
they drove around they were there
committing small burglary from cars that
were left unlocked but their fault yeah
so they would go in to these cards cars
and steal whatever they can get while
they were doing all that they saw that
there was a shirt helicopter overhead
and so they started slowing down they
turn off their life and then once a
traffic light they just sped off and
they want 120 miles an hour
they ran a red light they hit another
car this car that I'm talking about is a
Ford Ford Explorer okay the other one
was a Chrysler Sebring so this forward
Explorer hit another car and then
smashed into several parked cars hit a
pole it was launched into the air caught
on fire
Oh 220 miles an hour yeah and so three
out of the four teams that were in that
car died Wow yeah the lone survivor was
a 14 year old I was thrown out of the
back seat and so his brother 16 year old
was driving me for he was one of the
three that died oh did it die on impact
with the pole or they burned today I'm
not sure
damn I hope they died on impact yeah for
their sake yeah the man driving that car
she was sent to the hospital she had
internal bleeding a shattered collarbone
and a broken foot but he's comply now oh
good I wouldn't want a broken foot yeah
and then so the second car how do you
make it so not much but the collar
boatubia turtle Beattyville okay damn a
broken foot I don't mind a good turtle
bleeding is completely whatever did
[ __ ] crazy bro hey the foot is really
important to me right now your internal
organs are really important make all of
that [ __ ] work recently had a rib injury
but the foot thing like that's really
important for me you needed to take
right exactly
ah please smart Aeneas over here my
reader SL the second car the Sebring as
soon as I saw that the cop was on them
they immediately drove off they went
away from the car and they went oh so it
ended up with the helicopter followed
that car and they ended up abandoning
the car they were running on foot at the
end that are getting caught it was just
two teams a 16 year old and 18 year olds
and that 16 year old was when I stole
both cars they ended up catching the
survivors and so did you know the Ford
Explorer crashed I don't see it happen
no because they had already gone away at
that point as soon as like they started
getting chased they just split up and
then after the zebra got you know the
kids it from there they got caught the
cops asked them to go and identify this
friend's body and so the kids are just
saying like I he was sobbing he was like
please don't make me go I don't want to
go I don't want to have to get what the
[ __ ] you have to yeah so then the local
sheriff ended up holding a news
conference and he was suggesting murder
charges against the three surviving boys
he was also saying that in that area
there's just a persistent problem with
high speed joy rides and the fact that
the juvenile system is just broken
because these kids they have accumulated
126 arrests and they ended up going to
juvenile detention 46 times these same
kids or just generally in that area
another group of six kids oh I'm a
generation oh yeah you gotta take more
so they've had their chances already
yeah a lot of drastic measures yes
radiation parents beat the [ __ ] out of
them 46
yes that means I save had their chances
yeah so like first I think of things
like people have the ability to change
you know which I do a hundred percent
agree with 46 [ __ ] times
you ain't change it yeah they're taking
it actually now now you're just [ __ ]
around because you know like the ins and
outs like you're not going to keep me in
here forever and they did that and
people die so now this you go rotten
hell yeah cuz we with things to that the
juvenile system is holding them long
enough or obviously it's not expected
that they can rack up that many arrests
unlike that many times that they've gone
there simply gets that more in prison
dude to that achieve you quick yeah then
ladies clothes is not getting stabbed
anymore something come on there dude
where is this that again Florida Tampa
Tampa Tampa yeah so this is more - floor
that is even look like a call yeah and I
was an RT today we're like a tree that
fell over is like a stub yeah this is
the man I was injured in that car the 16
year old know anything about it be sixty
he look like [ __ ] this is the guy that
ended up carjacking he was in the
Sebring and then this is the 18 year old
that was with him all those guys iron is
but we go get you to Mike annual new
booty and then this is the lone survivor
of the for decor you through the window
you flip it from the back seat yeah
that's [ __ ] funny yeah fortunately it
is JA [ __ ] ugly there's a barber
Matic this turn a [ __ ] account how
easy 16 and then another 14 year old and
I'm Jordan Peele what the [ __ ] you can
rehab
and then 16 years do devil look weird
you know what he passed away and
hopefully we here I mean passed away
yeah I get it it's sad but you know 46
times offensive he stole a car jack
people and they almost killed somebody I
don't know where my sympathy goes for
that [ __ ] person some people would
argue that they deserved it so yeah well
a local man asking for it yeah they were
asking for it yeah the local lawyers are
thinking that the murder charges are a
stretch no it's not and that will be
difficult to carry out because they say
I think you have some real issues
charging a passenger a kid who wasn't
the driver with murder because there's a
matter of reasonable doubt
prosecutors would need to show that the
burglary and death of the three teens
were linked just because you can prove
the underlying felony that doesn't mean
a jury will automatically say okay
someone died as a result of these
actions oh but the driver died right the
gyrator that most the driver was Eliezer
to go to jail that's true that's kind of
like if there was a bank robbery and all
the bank robbers died but then you got
you get the lookout and you'd be like
okay I'm gonna give you the full
sentence yeah it's kind of [ __ ] up
yeah mm I don't know about that
because if you think about it there's no
turning back if they become adults in
jail that's it they're just a part of
that they don't get better you know I
feel actually really bad on a why I have
sympathy for the 14 year old I gotta
turn out the window he's 14 that's like
not far away from Isaac's age and that
14 to like it's like your brain is still
like it's a brick is it 14 to 16 is huge
you know into 18 is huge right so I had
14 year old years old and he's the one
that has a dead brother that was the
driver yeah maybe his lesson huh I was
stupid as [ __ ] out 14 my friend was like
let's go hold up that liquor store and I
was like okay how we gonna do it
50 people questioned it that was like
that sounds fun it was yeah 14 was a
stupid ass time we just walk around and
it's like I'm hungry you want some chips
okay and then like you know those
dairies they just have a bunch of chips
better like laid out we would run up a
grab
and run like I don't like a street rat
from Agrabah I would feel Apple and [ __ ]
you I'm so linic what's up you sexy
[ __ ] useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you want to follow us you could check
out all our [ __ ] link to the
description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ] than that videos are up there
[Music]